I've read some fantastic books lately.
Here are a few you might want to read this summer.
Lincoln in the Bardo by George Saunders
Anything about Lincoln is interesting.
I admire him and the tough things he faced,...
...including having his son die being among the worst.
And it is striking this balance between the tragedy of life and the joy of life.
It's about grief and purpose and it's very touching.
Everything Happens for a Reason by Kate Bowler
You've got this one person who's sick...
...and who is trying to figure out how they should deal with their bad news.
You don't want to think of outcomes as just being random,...
...you want to be able to connect them to something you control.
She's not asking you to cry for her.
She's just telling you what happened.
Origin Story by David Christian
The whole theory of Big History is to have a structure...
...that makes it easy to understand and explain things.
I think it helps people to have that understanding...
...that now we have big blocks of knowledge,...
...but the big blocks of knowledge relate to each other in a strong way.
For me, this broad knowledge of how all the pieces fit together,...
...you know, to me, that's interesting.
Factfulness by Hans Rosling
It's pretty fantastic...
...because it really talks through how you should think about the world.
For the first time in this book,...
...he teaches you a categorization of four tiers that is super helpful.
Leonardo da Vinci by Walter Isaacson
What Isaacson does is say what made da Vinci special.
He's most known for his art...
but he thought of himself as a military engineer and a scientist, and an expert on music,...
...and so he really defines the term Renaissance man.